hello there you're watching the press
preview a first look at what is on the
front pages as they arrive and it's time
to see what's making the headlines with
the director of demos think tank polly
mckenzie and the pr consultant alex dean
they'll be with us from now until just
before midnight thanks very much both of
you for joining us this fine friday
evening
let's see what's on the front of some of
those papers and the yorkshire post
leads on the resignation of the county
cricket club chairman after criticism
over the way the club handled
allegations of racist behavior
the eye says tory back benches are
furious with boris johnson oh his
support for the former mp owen patterson
who was found to have broken lobbying
rules
that's also the front of the express
which suggests voters could punish mr
johnson at the next election
labour's deputy leader angela raynor has
called on the standards commissioner to
open a new investigation into the
refurbishment of the prime ministerial
flat that is the lead in the guardian
vft reports on a new antiviral pill
produced by pfizer which drastically
cuts hospital admissions and deaths in
covert patients during clinical trials
the male says the new drug along with
more booster jabs will be crucial in the
fight against covet
there are calls for police officers to
be suspect subjected to random checks of
their phones in order to tackle online
misconduct that's the front of the times
well the telegraph reports that oxford
universities come under fire after it
accepted a multi-million pound donation
from the mosley family
on the front of the mirror the
footballer david gianola will be taking
part in the new series of i'm a
celebrity
and that is also the lead story for the
sun
well we are joined tonight by polly
mckenzie and alex dean uh nice to see
you both uh and we're gonna crack on
straight away with yorkshire and the
cricket and the front of the yorkshire
post um polly no surprise it's it's the
yorkshire post weekend's edition uh
front page headline um what are your
feelings about what's what's happened
today and and the resignations we've
seen and the new appointments do you
think that possibly puts a full stop to
the two at all
i don't think it does i mean this story
has been bubbling along for a few days
now and it has made it to the front of
the yorkshire post but
it's you know it's it's barely touched
on the front pages of the other papers
even though
every time we seem to pick at this story
more is uncovered uh the allegations at
the center of it
about racist behavior at the club in
past years are truly horrific
being dismissed as banter
the chairman here roger hatton who has
resigned alongside some other
non-executives um is saying in the
yorkshire post that he is in a way a
scapegoat
that he wanted the club to um
fess up basically admit wrongdoing uh
and and say that they wanted to you know
make a fresh start
and and move on from that but that there
was pressure from executive members who
he the the chairman ex-chairman is now
saying should resign
um
it just it i was so many of these
stories
you know the big part of it is the is
the is the bad behavior
but the second part of it that just
makes it so much worse is that attempt
to cover up and not to just admit admit
faults and it until i think that
yorkshire does that you will not get
that full stop
i mean what do you feel about it alex i
mean aside from the fact that this
obviously was a pretty a pretty grim
episode in the club's history they
haven't exactly covered themselves in
glory over the last couple of days have
they
well that's right jane it's a story of
two parts hit the past and present and
what happened then and how they dealt
with it in the much more recent uh past
when the allegations surfaced and one of
the many reasons this is such a sad and
bad story is that whilst there's racism
in
all sports and issues to be dealt with
in all walks of life i think if you ask
most people they would have said until
recently at least that cricket had
rather less of it than some of our other
top-tier sports and it's really sad to
see that this is the case in this sport
too i would say of course it's important
to stress that a lot some of these
allegations are
firmly denied by the people uh concerned
not least michael vaughan who you've
seen on the front couple of the covers
who deny saying the words that have been
attributed to him but there's no doubt
about it they have blundered in the way
that they have dealt with it and it's
not just the departures of executives
that shows that whilst that's the news
in tomorrow's newspapers it's also the
news we've already seen about the
departure of sponsors and i think if you
take those things together it's really
going to lead to a case for meaningful
change
polio are you surprised by by this in
the sense that you know as alex says
it's not something we've heard about
very much i mean why that is i suppose
it could be myriad reasons but but also
when you think of yorkshire crooked club
in particular it isn't really quite an
ethnically diverse area
it is and a sport that is played in
countries
you know all around the world with you
know i guess colonial links to the uk
but incredible diversity and actually
both you know the the you the england
qriket team has often had really
wonderful
diversity in its players and so yeah
yeah i think um you know the reality is
that as someone who is white you know we
all are here tonight
we do have what is now whether you want
to call it privilege or not that it's
very easy for us to sort of plunder
through the world not noticing racism
when it is occurring um and what's clear
from the allegations is that lots of
racist behavior which may have been sort
of
banter or well-meaning
but of course it isn't experienced that
way by those on the receiving end of it
and causes immense immense distress
it's so important when those allegations
do come out for us to recognize that
that yeah i absolutely like alex sort of
thought that
qriket was a bit different um and that
was arrogant complacency basically and i
think that the whole sport needs to
think very deeply about
having permitted a club a celebrated
brilliant club on the field
to have this kind of behavior you know
permitted
uh tolerated for so long
let's cheer ourselves up with something
that's slightly brighter alex at the
front of the daily mail the triple
covered boost i mean we did uh bring the
story about one uh new covered pill just
yesterday uh and this is another one i
mean
you know how how well have the
scientists done over covered it's just
astonishing isn't it
it's amazing progress and it's reason i
think that we can the most important
thing is that it points away from
further lockdowns and it points away
from further restrictions on a return to
what we will hope uh will one day be
normality again so the three big things
on the horizon are these pills
that apparently are going to greatly
reduce hospitalization access to
boosters for millions more of us
in short order and a steeply declining
case rate as you have been reporting
before the press preview all those
things taken together put a great bright
future um for our country and they point
to a great future i think for uh the way
that we deal with kovid going forward um
across the world of course we have heard
great positive news before and we
haven't quite got to where we thought we
were going to get to you know how many
times have we been told it's six weeks
to beat the curve and six months later
uh we still find that we're under some
form of significant restrictions so
let's not count chickens but it does
look fantastic it does feed um polly in
terms of the future not looking
particularly bright owen patterson was
somebody who this weekend will be
slightly wondering what's happened over
the last week perhaps
and the way that the government handled
what happened to him again the the
analysis of the of the of the reaction
rather than the event itself has turned
into the story hasn't it and tory mps a
lot of those who were whipped into
speaking into voting uh in the week are
are really angry about it aren't they
i think that's absolutely true and you
know owen patterson
it's very clear broke uh important
parliamentary rules and
was going to be sanctioned for that and
if he had accepted wrongdoing accepted
his punishment i think we would not
still be talking about this
and lots of those tory mps who were
pushed to vote with you know some
allegations now circling that they were
threatened that there would be spending
consequences for their constituencies if
they didn't support this owen paterson
vote to change uh that kind of
supervisory uh sanction system for mps
it
are immensely immensely furious because
of course it's one thing
to
take that political pain
excuse me quite another to take that
political pain and and then you turned
the next day
meaning that absolutely all of that
political pain was completely
unnecessary and you know some are
suggesting that there's particularly an
interesting generational divide you know
the conservatives did really well
remember in the 2019 general election
huge number of new members of parliament
new relatively new to politics certainly
knew um uh in terms of the the
constituencies that they were elected
for and they feel that they've
essentially been stiffed with their
constituents to defend one of the old
guard a different generation of
politicians who who perhaps represents a
different way of behaving
okay we'll get your thoughts on that a
little bit later alex but we're going to
take a short break now thank you very
much polly and alex coming up after the
break we're going to be looking at why a
watchdog is demanding random whatsapp
checks for police officers mobiles
that's after the break
[Music]
well we've been uh cutting carbon for
two decades ian actually i joined google
in 2007 i was a child really and in
those days we went carbon neutral and
then since then what we've been doing is
investing heavily in renewables so 2017
we matched all of our electricity
purchases globally with renewable energy
with a bigger big investor in wind and
solar and so on and we've announced our
plan to be carbon free only operating on
renewables by 2030 in our campuses and
data centers the good news is
in through two or three data centers in
europe we're already running only on
renewables over 90 of the time so we're
getting towards that the last 10 is hard
but i think it's a really important
thing for people to understand every
time you search or watch a youtube video
you're already carbon neutral and we're
well on the way to being carbon free
we're trying to help users make smarter
choices too so one of our pledges is to
help a billion users
using our products in their everyday
lives to make smarter choices for the
planet so good example there is google
maps probably the most useful thing we
can do is show you the most eco-friendly
route and we're doing that and so if the
most eco-friendly route is very similar
in time to the rest we'll just give you
that if it's a bit of a difference in
time we'll show you the option because
sometimes you'll be able to make that
choice and we estimate that we could
take the equivalent of 200 000 cars off
the streets
if people are using those kinds of tools
or when you search for a product or a
flight or a hotel we want to be able to
show you the more eco-friendly options
so that's one of the ways that we can
help consumers make smarter choices and
by the way we know that people really
care over 70 of people in countries
around the world
care about and are fearful of the
consequences of climate change and
that's why it's so urgent that we take
action it's clear that governments and
companies and communities need to work
together to do this and that's why
google's trying to play its part
we're one of the world's biggest
purchasers in the corporate sector of
renewable energy we invest we're often
the first investor in things like a wind
or a solar farm so that we bring new
capacity online that others can benefit
from what we've found is actually by
doing that we've reduced our energy
costs you know these new renewables can
be as cost efficient uh as older types
of energy and i think one of the key
things at cop is for governments to give
that framework for decarbonization
for more finance to help to assist that
transition transparent carbon markets
and to incentivize innovation
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back you're watching the press
preview
with me now to look through the front
page as the director of the demo think
tank polly mckenzie and the pr
consultant alex dean we've had a good
look through quite a few of them already
um but alex let's turn our attention to
the front of the daily telegraph
this is about one of the oxford colleges
which has taken money from max mosley
who died recently and and they're being
called hypocrites why
because the money is at least in part
traceable it is alleged to oswald mosley
who was the founder of the british
uniform he's the leader of some time of
the british union of fascists um it's a
challenging thing for institutions when
they are offered money
from high net worth individuals to
ascertain where the wealth came from on
this occasion you might think that the
name is a bit of a giveaway but i think
that actually um the sins of the father
are not visited upon the sun and mostly
whilst he had his own reputational um
quibbles questions uh and interesting
issues that arose um in his lifetime uh
was not so fascist in fact he in many
ways was a charitable and admirable man
the difficulty i think a lot of
institutions face art galleries are the
kind of number one and colleges like
this are number two is that sometimes
they really need the money so that's the
first question for them and the second
uh issue i think quite often uh facing
institutions like this is that whatever
the source of the wealth the money is
supposedly going to go and do some good
right i mean even though oxford is
obviously a complete dump uh this might
go and help some education so you know
if you take those things together you
might think there's a good reason to
take uh money from people but if you've
been going around saying roads must fall
for ages then it might make you seem a
bit hypocritical i mean probably would
this trouble you or or do you think as
alex says that you know at least
however that this money was was forged
it is actually being now used for
something good
i think it's really important for
institutions to have open conversations
with
the people who make up that institution
you know in this case the the educators
the students the the people of oxford i
think you know in the end what matters
most to me at least is what the money is
used for
not where it came
and i think it does matter what you
choose to
call things um
and so
you know there's some controversy in
particular about whether donations given
partly in honor of max mosley's son who
took his own life died by suicide um
should that therefore lead to his name
being on buildings in his honor
the problem is that it is a mosley name
which of course um
you know suggests uh all sorts of links
and suggests that there might be any a
link to oswald mosley and i think that
the question of what we name things big
buildings big institutions honorary
fellowships whatever they are does
suggest that sense of celebration and so
i think we should be cautious about
naming things after people with a more
complicated history but focus most of
all our attention on what is the money
being used for and i think that as alex
says there is a lot that oxford
university can do that is good um with
this money indeed very very briefly uh
the front of the times um alex this is a
story um in light of a lot of stories
that we've seen over the past few months
of issues with police officers on the
job as a suggestion that their phones
should be checked random checks on
policemen's and women's whatsapp groups
even their private phones good idea
well in light of some of the things that
have happened on uh private messaging
services with our police halls up to and
including serving officers taking bodies
of corpses and sending them to their
friends you can understand why people
are so deeply concerned about this the
trouble is that when you institute
something like this if you don't change
the culture then all you do is you catch
the very stupid people who are doing
this whilst the others if they want to
carry on doing it move it to some other
more encrypted or secret service in the
end the problem isn't the system the
method by which they send it the problem
is the culture in which they want to
send it in the first place okay we're
going to pause there uh alex and polly
thank you both very very much indeed for
taking through your choices
you